welcome back ross stripling he last
pitched on
april the 8th that was against los
angeles angels he was then put on the
injured list on april the 12th with the
right forearm flexor strains
ground ball right back to the mound easy
inning for
stripping three up three down six
pitches and he has a very quick inning
ian anderson who's on a great role in
rotation for atlanta
yep 2-0 248 on the year you see his
numbers in inner league play he's been
fantastic in three starts 3-0 with a 145
and a swing and a miss i'd say it worked
pretty well with the first batter
springers retired for route number one
yeah that's about as good as you can do
there good pitch there
front door slider as this ball is
whacked in the air towards center field
and right there is poche and ian
anderson's able to pitch around
austin riley's throwing air ozzie albees
will lead off for the braves who went
down one two three in the opening inning
ozzie lifts one toward left guriel going
back look at the wind grab ahold of that
a tie off the wall
well played by guriel to hold ozzy to a
double and look at stripling his hands
were
pointed to the heavens is it are you
kidding me
wind blowing out hit it high watch it
fly here's pablo sandoval the braves
designated hitter
i didn't miss the high fastball gets
sandoval that's the first
strikeout for stripping two-two pitch
missed another high fastball does the
trick back-to-back strikeouts for
strickland
this one golf to the left side beshet
with a backhand
long throw and guerrero leaps high to
keep that from going into the camera
well
austin reilly with an infield hit tough
play for beshette
and reilly legs it out braves have their
second hit of the inning
and william contreras the braves young
catcher bats for the first time in the
bigs
this year next smoked into left field
welcome to the show william contreras
that will score ozzy albees and a wild
throw
comes in toward third base contreras
with his first at back drives home the
game's first run and atlanta has action
with two outs they lead one-nothing
that told you could hit got a hanging
breaking ball and hammered it
i should help him relax a little bit not
that i don't think he was
not relaxed but he looks like a pretty
cool customer most of the time
that's a nice smooth simple swing there
was yep richard's been on a tear the
last nine games he's hitting just shy of
300
and how about that base hit to start his
afternoon
i'll tell you what i love it and it's
about time hitters taking advantage of
the shifts and randall is a very
powerful guy but he just stroked that
ground ball through the hole on the
right side danny janssen will come to
the plate with
runners at first and second there is a
base hit
and that's gonna make the throw to the
plate here comes grishik around and he
slides in
under the tag and danny jensen ties it
up
he snaps that old for 35. boy that'll
get the teammates fired up for you
there's nothing better than that the
snapping over with an
rbi hit he stayed on that ball
here's marcus simeone he fly out to
center field his only timer
it's a 1-1 game we're in the bottom of
the third inning two outs
[Applause]
that's gonna be a fair ball but shed
will come in to score
guerrero is headed for third he's
getting the wave around third
the relay throw will not be in time as
there's no throw to the plated marcus
obsidian
for their two rbi double
for simian that's his first double of
the season give him
12 rbis now and the blue jays have a 3-1
lead well here's danny jansen he has
snapped that long over ground boss gonna
sneak through for another knock
stay hot danny he's two for two boy he's
gonna be walking on air after
today's game springer jumps back and
that ball goes all the way back to the
backstop it'll be another wild pitch
second of the day
thrown by ian anderson as jensen goes to
second so here's beau bechet he's been
on base
twice so far reached on an air in the
first had a single and scored in the
third
oh it's another one to the gap in right
center that's going to get down and go
up against the wall
jackson's in the score bushets headed
for second he'll get there with a
stand-up rbi
neville bow bouchette's swinging it this
afternoon
this is just good hitting this is so
hard to teach to take that ball that's
away like that and
inside out and still get solid wood on
the ball
and put it up the alley in right center
field
i mean that's just a thing of beauty or
he can flat out here
there's no getting around it austin
reilly will lead things off as
our stripling is working in the fifth
inning
rifle to the left side and through riley
is two for two today
so stripling will have to work out of
the stretch and contreras is coming up
he's got the braves rbi
that's a great attack so it's set up for
atlanta
so let's see what christian can do at
the very least advance the runners for
cuny and freeman
lays down a bunt it is perfect
bases are loaded for acuna the a1
is high fly ball deep center at the wall
it's caught by grichik reilly tags up on
scores
another bullet off the bat of acuna he
just missed
a grand slam and that's going to be the
end of the line for stripping as the
braves are measuring him up
that cuts the lead to two it's four to
two now
and contreras had to really fly to get
back to second
he and acuna thought it was gone ryan
berecki comes into the ball game to face
freddie freeman
rocky with an 02 count swinging miss he
strikes out freeman on
three pitches
[Applause]
he comes in with two aboard and strikes
out and freddie freeman and marzello's
soon
chatwood will take over here he pitched
in yesterday's ball game right about the
same spot in the lineup
ground has to wait on the big second hop
second for one back for first
double play well what a nice double play
good turn to second by
sidion one two count on pasha
strike three call that fastball catches
the outside
corner another terrific inning for tyler
chatwood
david phelps has been just fine this
year look at that earned run average
under one in 10 games he's thrown nine
in a third innings went
another strikeout for david phelps that
breaking ball gets secundum
two-two pitch cut on a missed he goes
down swinging once again that was a
terrific change-up from
two away breaking bar he swings and
misses and david
phelps gets three strikeouts in the
inning now they're going to try and add
on against
shawn newcomb how about that is back
pando grichik is rewarded with a sharp
single into left field
on the 13th pitch on the 12th pitch of
the inbound
fly ball to left field back this ball is
gonna go about
that for a home run marcus is a
two-round
home run a four rbi day the home run
number six
for simeon okay
okay i'll take it i said add on a run
i'll take the two runs right there
and guerillas got himself a base hit
and he's hustling towards second here's
the throw from pasha
and with a nifty slide avoids the tag of
albies
jerry meals the umpire at second they're
going to ask for a review
as they will review the tag play but
curiel boy what a
nifty slide he put on albie's
panic hits this one into the alley in my
center that's gonna get down and go
on to the warning trap dorial comes in
to score panic is headed for secondary
get in there with a slide an rdi double
for joe panic
papillon was up in the eighth inning
anticipating a possible save situation
abuja scored three runs in the bottom of
the eighth he sat back down and now
payments has loaded the bases and here's
dolis with
two outs one and two
struck him out and the blue jays win it
so
elise comes in and gets the strikeout
his third save of the season and the
blue jays
indeed sweep the three-game series over
at atlanta